i've been an iphone user ever since the
iphone 6 and now i own an iphone 13 pro
max which i love because it finally has
the 120 hertz promotion display which
works very well while also having pretty
much the best battery life that you can
get on any flagship phone however
samsung just released their galaxy s22
ultra and i've been playing around with
it for over a week now and i've gotta
say that i'm pretty impressed but at the
same time there are a couple of things
that i'm disappointed about so in this
video i'm gonna talk about my experience
with the s22 ultra over the past week
including both the pros and the cons
because yes this phone is definitely not
perfect but before i get into that let's
talk about the differences in design
first of all i absolutely love the
design of the s22 ultra compared to the
old s21 ultra which i absolutely
couldn't stand because first of all you
got this massive metal brick
of a camera bump that's basically welded
to the side i can't stand it it's just
so chunky and now
this new design with the separated
camera bumps and the contrast especially
with this new white finish this looks
absolutely amazing and it destroys the
old design it just looks so good and
comparing it to the current iphone 13
pro max design first of all i have a
leather skin from nomad i love this skin
but i'd honestly say that this new
design of the s22 ultra basically beats
out the iphone because honestly i'm
getting kind of bored of this look in
this design and this just looks so clean
to me and now i do want to mention that
the s21 ultra was the first s series to
get s pen support but what really
annoyed me was that you had to carry the
s pen outside of the s21 ultra because
it didn't have any slot for the s pen
like the new s22 ultra does thankfully
because it's basically built with the
same note design as the note 20 ultra
it's basically the same thing rebranded
as an s22 and i honestly do not mind
because i love this design and i love
that you get to store the s pen inside
of the actual phone itself and now
another thing that i really like about
this s22 ultra is that this year samsung
completely differentiated it from the
lower end s22 and s22 plus so now you
actually get a different design and
better design with the ultra model
compared to previous years where they
all basically look the same and there
wasn't really a good reason to pay for
the ultra and compared to the iphone
another thing i really like about it is
that you have those rounded edges on the
sides so it fits into your palm nicely
and even though it's basically a bigger
phone than the iphone it seems to fit
better than the 13 pro max which has
these flat sides so it kind of digs into
your palm a little bit and it feels
thicker feels kind of like a brick
compared to this nice and smooth s22
ultra and then of course it has the
single camera hole punch which looks
incredibly clean and so much better than
the notch even though the 13 pro max got
a smaller notch this just looks miles
better and i know that we have rumors
for the next iphone 14 pro coming with
that new dual pill shaped plus cutout
design so i'm really excited for that
but even with that dual design i think
the single camera cutout is still more
clean but of course this doesn't have
any kind of special face id system or
anything like that which the iphone has
and it works incredibly well so i'm
gonna give apple a break here because
face id i'd say is still better than the
under display touch id on the s22 ultra
even though this is faster than previous
years you literally can't beat face id
because it now supports masks so there's
literally no drawback to face id and i
think it is miles better than any kind
of under display fingerprint scanner and
now with the design out of the way and
before i get into the performance i want
to talk about some of the quality of
life features that are really important
to me like for example the speakers i am
completely disappointed in these
speakers because the ones on the iphone
sound better in pretty much every way
they're louder they have sharper and
higher highs they have much more bass
and the overall sound stage is basically
wider sounds so much better and i know
you guys didn't believe us when we
showed you in our hands-on comparison so
we ended up comparing the s22 ultra to
both the old s21 ultra and the note 20
ultra all of them with dolby atmos
turned on and yes we proved that both of
those phones actually sound better than
the new s22 ultra which is really weird
and it makes no sense at all but that's
the reality and our theory for this is
that the s22 ultra has basically the
same chassis design as the note 20 ultra
but it packs a larger 5 000 milliamp
hour battery compared to 4500 which
obviously cuts down on the internal
space so maybe samsung had to make the
speaker enclosures a little bit smaller
to fit in the larger battery but either
way i am disappointed in the speakers
now in terms of the display samsung made
some massive claims saying that the
display can go up to 1750 nits which is
very impressive compared to the iphone's
1200 nits however when we started
testing it and comparing it to the
iphone we started noticing some issues
first of all after turning on the extra
brightness setting turning off adaptive
brightness and manually adjusting both
the s22 ultra and the iphone to maximum
brightness they ended up looking
basically the same but then i came
across a photo that golden reviewer
posted on twitter showing that the s22
was actually brighter so we ended up
running some tests and we discovered
that if both phones are on a white page
similar to google's homepage they're
basically the same in terms of
brightness but when you switch over to
something that has much less white on
the display the s22 ultra does in fact
get brighter than the iphone so what
this tells us is that samsung dims down
the display depending on how much white
is on the screen to help save battery
life and just to confirm that this is
true we ran an oled abl test which
cycles between small and large white
boxes and as you can see when the box
gets smaller the s22 ultra's display
gets significantly brighter compared to
the iphone which stays basically flat in
terms of brightness no matter how big
the white box is and then when the box
gets larger the samsung dims down close
to around as bright as the iphone and
then when you go to the full white page
like we did earlier you can see that in
this case the iphone was actually a
little bit brighter and just to make
these completely fair we compared the
s22 ultra to both the s21 ultra and the
note 20 ultra outside in bright daylight
with adaptive brightness on and to our
surprise the s22 ultra wasn't any
brighter at all no matter what we tried
making sure that all the settings were
turned on so because of that we opened
up an hdr video within youtube where it
definitely should have shined and it
looked the worst out of all three phones
by far which made no sense at all and
yes it was also worse than the iphone 13
pro max so i'm not sure if there's some
kind of software issue going on that
samsung needs to fix but it's a bit
disappointing compared to what samsung
led us to believe with the whole 1750
nit brightness claim now moving forward
a couple of other things were a bit
disappointing even though samsung didn't
necessarily make any big claims like
they did with the brightness but when we
compared the 5g speeds of the new s22
ultra to the older phones unfortunately
within our concrete office building the
older s21 ultra performed better getting
almost two times faster download speeds
than the s22 ultra and then when we went
outside on the roof the old s21 ultra
was consistently giving us higher upload
speeds than the new one which is also a
bit weird so maybe there's a chance that
samsung's trying to give this thing
better battery life by maybe tuning down
the power of the 5g antenna i'm not sure
but i expected to get the best
performance with this thing and we
didn't and then speaking of battery life
while we didn't do a battery drain test
ourselves mr who's the boss did and he
concluded that the new s22 ultra
actually got worse battery life than the
old s21 ultra which doesn't make any
sense at all because the new one has a
bit less resolution it comes with a new
more efficient four nanometer chip which
they advertised as well as the new
display that can go down to one hertz
refresh rate instead of 10 hertz on the
old model so there's no excuse for
having a decrease in battery life with
the new model so i went back to mr who
is the boss's previous iphone battery
drain test and apparently the regular
6.1 inch iphone 13 pro gets better
battery life than the new s22 ultra with
the 13 pro max model that i have
absolutely destroying it by over two
hours and once again let me remind you
that this comes with the newest 4
nanometer snapdragon 8 gen 1 chip
compared to apple's 5 nanometer a15
bionic so it should technically be more
efficient but it's not and now moving
over to the actual performance the
overall snappiness of the ultra is great
but i did have some issues in terms of
high performance gaming when playing
gentian impact at maxed out settings the
s22 ultra seems to run at a lower frame
rate compared to the iphone which was
confirmed by golden reviewer on youtube
who tracked the fps on both phones over
a 15 minute gaming session showing that
the iphone averaged at 59.2 fps almost
perfect while the s22 ultra ran at 33.5
almost two times lower now in my
personal experience the iphone still has
a bit of a display dimming issue if your
brightness is set to 80 or higher so the
s22 ultra has the advantage there
because of the better cooling system now
in many of the other common games that
aren't as demanding like car mobile it
ran just fine with no issues at all
given you a great gaming experience but
the biggest problem that i had that
really disappointed me was that within a
lot of my favorite games like league of
legends wild rift and pokemon unite you
are not able to go up to 120 fps
on the s22 ultra which is a big deal if
you want to stay competitive and this
really sucks because the iphone 13 pro
max can run at basically perfect 120 fps
and both of those games with no issues
while the samsung couldn't even run at a
solid 60fps in pokemon unite which was
really weird and of course looking at
the benchmarks the iphone destroys the
samsung in basically every way which is
pretty unfortunate but the final saving
grace of the s22 ultra is the new camera
updates and to be honest samsung
absolutely nailed it this year with very
clear improvements and i know this for
sure because we made an unbiased blind
camera comparison against the new iphone
13 pro where max took photos with his
family on both of these phones and our
main editor angelica and i voted for
which photos we like the best and in my
case the samsung easily won the test
while angelica got a tie
and then we compared the s22 ultra to
both the note 20 ultra and the s21 ultra
and it was a massive win for the new
model making it clear that samsung
killed it in terms of the cameras but
all in all i think samsung has created
the best flagship smartphone that
they've made in years especially in
terms of the design and camera quality
but i'm still a bit disappointed about a
few of the features like the display
brightness claims the lackluster speaker
quality and the upsetting gaming
performance and in terms of how it
compares to the iphone i think they're
just about neck and neck considering the
fact that the s22 ultra is more
expensive so i honestly wouldn't want to
switch to it especially since i really
love ios and i'm looking forward to the
new iphone 14 pro max which i think is
gonna destroy this phone in multiple
ways so hopefully you enjoyed this
review and if you did go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one definitely check
out our camera comparisons and our tests
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you